[Music]
coral reefs are some of the most diverse
places on the planet
[Music]
but it's not easy being a small fish on
a big reef
tiny animals must overcome huge
challenges
to keep their coral city alive
for this production we have wonderful
gadgets that we filmed with
the closed circuit rebreather is
revolutionary
for filming animal behavior
[Music]
all of the gas that you're breathing
stays contained within this one unit
and you don't blow bubbles anymore and
the animals are just so
much more comfortable around you they're
not scared off with every single
exhale that you make it's just amazing
how much closer you can get to all the
fish
and how much longer you can stay down
there
today we were searching for a peacock
mantis shrimp
which are a colorful animal that lives
in a hole that it builds itself in the
reef
it looks amazing on the probe you know
being actually below it and like looking
at it
it's so encouraging to find a really
good animal and so encouraging to start
to see the visual with these new scopes
that we're using on this series
got a cool shot on actually now like
looking super aggressive and then
broke my probe just like came up just
smashed the front of it
sometimes nature just gets yellow
[Music]
we witnessed this absolutely massive
crown of thorns outbreak but these tiny
little red crabs live in coral colonies
and when a crown of thorns puts his arm
up over the top of the coral
these tiny little crabs they nip away at
the tube feet
and at the spines of the crown of thorn
the crown of thorn
turns around really quickly and starts
going the other way
so it was awesome actually just seeing
these
tiny little crabs defending their home
their little coral colony
it was amazing a diverse community of
tiny creatures
all playing their part keeps coral reefs
healthy
and far more resilient to the many
threats they face
tiny world
you